merci la parole est à Madame ellisabeth
Lamur pour le groupe UMP merci merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question est pour Madame
Pinel madame la ministre un nouveau
feuilleton sème la perplexité car il se
déroule sur fond de
cacophonie vous travaillez sur la
réforme du dispositif de
l'auto-entrepreneur et il y a quelques
jours le gouvernement a fait un certain
nombre de révélations à ce sujet par la
voix de plusieurs ministres mais des
voix pour le moins discordantes vous
annonciez vous-même le 23 mai des
mesures destinées à restreindre la durée
et l'activité des auto-entrepreneurs
c'est alors que des centaines de
milliers de poussins se sont fait
entendre le Premier ministre a
immédiatement déclaré vendredi dernier
que les mesures se limiteraient au
secteur du bâtiment et que pour les
autres il n'y avait pas d'inquiétude à
avoir dans le même sens le ministre du
Budget indiquait que Bery ne procéderait
qu'à des changements à la marge ensuite
vous-même madame la ministre vous avez
av en quelque sorte tenté de rétablir la
vérité en déclarant que Jean-Marc hraud
avait cité le bâtiment comme exemple
qu'on avait mal interprété ses propos
mais que la réforme ne se limiterait pas
au seul secteur du bâtiment et dire que
récemment Laurent Fabius se félicitait
d'entendre moins de quoi qu'au
gouvernement au final dans ce dossier
quelles sont les intentions du
Gouvernement vous avez beaucoup décréé
ce régime pourtant vous ne semblez pas
vouloir le supprimer nous l'avions
nous-même modifier et améliorer après
avoir écouté les professionnels vous
ferez sans doute vos propres
propositions pour rapprocher les
auto-entrepreneurs des régimes de
l'artisanat mais vous qui êtes justement
ministre de l'Artisanat la meilleure
manière d'aider les artisans c'est de
baisser leurs charges c'est de
simplifier leurs démarches suite été de
ne pas augmenter leur cotisation pas
plus que d'augmenter la TVA au 1er
janvier prochain là seraiit les bonnes
mesures pour favoriser entrepreneuriat
que nous soutenons souffler en
permanence le chaud et le froid annoncer
tout et son contraire et de nature à
inquiéter alors au milieu de ce Brou de
déclaration contradictoire apportez-nous
une clarification nous en avons tous
besoin et les entrepreneurs plus que les
autres bien merci la parole à Sylvia
Pinel ministre de l'Artisanat du
Commerce et du
Tourisme merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice ellisabeth Lamur
vous m'interrogez sur la réforme du
régime de l'auto-entrepreneur que le
gouvernement souhaite conduire je
regrette le ton polémique que vous avez
employé
caricatural vous vous m'interrogez sur
un sujet important qui concerne de
nombreux Français qui constituent
l'essentiel de nos TPE et qui mérite
de clarifier et de reformuler un certain
nombre de propos que vous déformez vous
êtes vous-même dans une famille
politique qui ici ou là peut demander
une évolution législative du régime de
l'auto-entrepreneur c'est le cas de
certains députés UMP à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi le cas de certains
députés de l'UMP lors de la commission
des affaires économiques qui explique
qu'il y a un effet certains écueils à ce
régime donc parlez-moi de la cohérence
vous qui semblez aujourd'hui dire
qu'aucune réforme n'est nécessaire alors
je vais vous présenter madame la
sénatrice les trois objectifs que vise
le gouvernement dans cette réforme
d'abord c'est de préserver préserver ce
régime qui a permis de libérer l'esprit
d'entreprendre qui a permis par sa
simplicité de faciliter la création
d'entreprise le deuxème objectif c'est
de l'améliorer de le rendre plus clair
plus efficace pour permettre de
développer de véritables
projets d'entreprendre et de ne pas voir
cela comme un statut précaire ce que
vous n'avez pas voulu faire puisque vous
n'avez pas souhaiter accompagner ces
auto-entrepreneurs pour passer à la
vitesse supérieure nous nous le
proposons nous voulons enfin corriger
certaines lacunes certaines erreurs des
témoignages de plus en plus nombreux me
parviennent sur lete contournement du
droit du travail en matière de salariat
déguisé c'est aussi un des objectifs de
de cette réforme c'est la raison pour
laquelle je poursuis cette cette
concertation au nom du gouvernement j'ai
reçu ce matin les organisations
professionnelles de l'artisanat qui ont
fait des proposition je reçois tout à
l'heure les fédérations des
auto-entrepreneurs parce que l'objectif
du gouvernement c'est de réconcilier
tous les entrepreneurs de France pour la
réussite économique de notre pays